I have no idea what just happened
um we will
see why the heck is the CPU running so
hot from just like this basic like not
that
hard
again this should not be that hard for
this thing to
run
uh hold
on
does this work
now okay I think I'm not allowed to
click outside of this window
um yeah it works okay cool so this just
cut my stream in half but yeah this is
there was a little intro before this um
the idea is we're building a card game
sim and I have an awkward amount of time
so I'm kind of just going to try to
figure out what's going on here I've
never played magic I've watched some
content about
it y y Commander I don't know what this
is by default this is whatever default
arena
is do
these okay
okay you tapped lands on yeah okay I
play a
land and I can summon a second one right
shorten for tutorial yeah one of them
can
attack this can attack
right and
then what what is the UI with
this I'm hoping the animations go faster
than this
right all go
face oh wait no
I forget yes okay this is one of the
games in which you are you can choose
your block cool yes Hearthstone is the
one where you cannot choose
block can I like make all these
animations to go
fast well obviously I don't need the
animations in the
end there's no this minion
attacks one of them is declare all
attacks okay
why is this
uh will it destroy it'll destroy one of
them won't
it can I not just attack anyways okay
don't
attack yeah I figured I could just go
face and it would block it would hit
two I don't
through okay he takes two even a small
clature backs blocks all damage okay
cool
creature unless the opposing teacher has
trample no extra Okay cool so I these
are just all variations on things I know
cool tap All Creatures your opponent
control controlls
cool tap creatures cannot okay so now
they're tap so I can go face and win
yeah that's the tutorial
cool and it gives me a card cool untap
it start a turn yep is there a freaking
option
for are there options to disable a bunch
of like to make stuff go
aren't also let me just make sure I have
my email up on the side here because I
told somebody that uh I forgot to
confirm a meeting and I told somebody I
could be at Coffee in 15 minutes if they
uh if they
reply
cool attacks tend to go faster once you
play okay that's fine so this thing has
haste
[Music]
cool you can play one land per turn
right that's how it works yep
ahead
Locker chat
[Music]
so
uh heal all damage at the end of
turn this goes
here this
cool and these can't do anything so no
attacks yada
yada make an RL agent why do you think
I'm streaming this at the moment because
we are doing
that or at least we're considering it
I've got some more meetings later
today I'll consider making a little bit
of it open in the Discord actually I'd
be happy to chat with some people on
Discord uh later in the evening about
ideas for this
this did you know magic is Turing
complete completely irrelevant so is so
is the instruction
move the move instruction is also turn
complete doesn't
matter so uh are you supposed to just
lose to this as part of the tutorial is
this just like hey aggro decks are hard
or like what what is this I guess it's
like
okay you heal
[Music]
and these things
yeah uh this thing can
block how would you make an
environment I feel that would be
incredibly time-taking
well that's what I'm why that's what I'm
doing at the moment is I'm trying to
figure out how hard like all these
mechanics would be to
implement and seven and
three uh so he'll
block I think either way he just dies
here right
yeah I don't know I think having like a
basic the thing that's going to be uh
this doesn't do anything uh having a a
basic card game like a basic card engine
type thing is not going to take very
long at all um it's just like all the
effects and stuff and Magic that are
going to be I have to get a sense of how
hard it will be for various effects
I mean a lot of cards have like similar
effects so I think that we can get a
decent group of them pretty quickly but
like I I know that there things like
triggers and stuff keywords are easy but
things like triggers are hard unlocked
cards cool
do you have 15 life or is this just a
tutorial I thought you had like 20 or 40
or
something island flying
cool can't be blocked yeah
whatever do
this uh one two put
this cool
you get 20 okay so it's just a
please okay it's just a tutorial being
stupidly slow come
on this is like the single digit number
of brain cell tutorial
uh
three so I can't play this I can play
this 2
two better on this thing but probably I
just do
this so I've played briefly I briefly
played Legends of run
Terra um
and that's a and I've watched a bunch of
card game content that's it for context
here which is why I'm currently doing
this because it one of the dumbest
things you can do in RL is to try to
like do anything without understanding
the
environments like literally that's the
most important
thing completely Justified research
stream I'm probably just going to play
the tutorial right now is all I'm going
to do and then I'll have a
um you gain can this heal you over
Max
three oh well I don't have land hold on
this auto play cool just do
this all
attack
this I think this works right he blocks
this but I don't take damage right
okay Enchanted creature gets plus two
plus
two enchantment
Aura uh okay can I not do this do I not
have land for this
oops no I do cockatrice which should be
a
Sandbox oh I'll check it out for uh the
structure but like we're going to build
something that runs a million steps a
second if we're going to do
anything oh Ultra ultra high perf is the
name of the
game like I think I could knock out a
basic card game sim in like a thousand
lines of C in a weekend um obviously
like the full thing is a lot more
but I need to get a better sense of the
mechanics to know what type of stuff
will be hard
yada enchant and has
flying uh what's he have he has a 4
six and he has a 2 two do I do
this I think that's
better yeah now you can't kill anything
with the
block and I have to deal six this turn
to not lose right
yeah yeah can these can we skip all the
voice lines
please
um
O Okay so wait
six so I need to do this and then
enchant this so that he can't survive
with blocks right
yeah and then I just win cool
all
right that was not
hard uh
continue
play the hardest thing so far is waiting
for animations to
finish I mean as well like to implement
I don't think a couple of these effects
so far would be a little tricky we
haven't gotten anything that triggers
yet
though is there not like a mute voice
lines
thing
this is probably going to be the uh the
tutorial for like they have spells or
whatever right yeah so they have a
reaction yeah they have an instant
emails looks like I'm not
well I guess I messed up I I forgot to I
was supposed to have a coffee chat but I
forgot to uh to
confirm so I guess he just assumed I
wasn't
available my
bad uh
yeah do you have more of
these no you just have a flash
creature
okay I don't understand what this
supposed to
work sacrifice a creature draw two cards
cool
but then it goes face if you do that
right oh wait how did that just work
wait so it blocked but then it's got
sacrificed so I don't get the hit that's
weird deals one damage for each swamp
Okay
enters lock
first oh this is an in okay this is the
instance tutorial
right okay yeah I get it it's just I
don't get the order these things are
resolved in but I see what's happening
okay
cool so I have to understand the order
of the stack or whatever Target block
creature next I'll
right how does this wait you can block
with two things is is this a
thing Target blocking or blocked
creature okay so we do this and now it
just defeat it just hits both of them
right
yeah confront the assault
create three tokens with flying
cool so I'm sure that there's going to
be some reaction
no yeah so you're going to make a bunch
of these and then I have to play this to
block sure right
Ed creature
[Music]
cool and one more
tutorial was it 340
click click
click y next
Advance
okay I know this is an iconic uh this is
like an iconic Commander or something
okay uh do you discard last
here do you assume that you draw more
uh I don't want to attack with this
right
yeah okay so this is the pulling dragon
from graveyard right this is Graveyard
mechanic right
y and
and three and two do I block with this
yeah I
do so I do one blocker and then I do oh
wait plus two plus two so I could
destroy the
dragon but then this dies or I can
destroy this and live which I don't know
is that better
this gain four life
um never
another enters you gain one life and
draw a
card three four I can't play this
anyways I have to just play this
it's kind of funny like actually I'm
realizing that many of the times you
don't really have very many
choices right based on what is
legal you actually have very few
choices so actually if you if you parse
the action space of this
correctly the branching Factor should be
quite small in many
cases two damage to flying
okay big
spell draws seven
cards what in the heck
if a creature is attacking to you you
can create some tokens
cool yeah we don't do
this so these are both tapped but I
don't have yeah I don't have the card
for this
cast wait cast a
spell oh wait wait these okay I just
misre yeah sure we do this and then this
blocks everything because you full Block
in Magic
right oh and then these activate on
tokens so you gain a ton of these
things uh but I don't have any more Mana
so I can only do
this if you wanted to do card and RL how
would you en code the
text rather you'd have to have a
specific property yeah it would be
basically a set of properties like
internally the game has like represent
that has properties that represent a lot
of this stuff I'm sure um so you
wouldn't encode the text you would
encode properties into a struct of some
type the network architecture is going
to be a little bit
hairy wait what I Target blocked
creature gains plus two plus two that
doesn't do anything even if if I use
that it doesn't kill anything so we just
do
this but yeah that's what I was looking
at
essentially uh
ples
cat and this is for
blocked Target blocking or blocked
creature does this mean
can I use this when I
attack well this doesn't do anything if
I attack here
right wait are we going to RL magic that
would be dope what what do you think I'm
doing here I'm trying to figure out
figure that
out purely based on syntax
that'd be interesting I mean Hearthstone
is very keywords Z so that would
probably be easier but uh
yeah yes you can
well I mean hey I you know what folks I
will host something in Discord later
this evening in a few hours um it'll
probably I have a bunch of other stuff
to do so it might be well I'm working
out or something we'll see but I will uh
I will host something in the Discord and
we can chat about it
teacher the man well thank
you I actually have a surprising number
of people interested in this project as
well so I have a meeting shortly about
this uh I had one earlier today keep
your angel
alive
okay choose your
blockers targeting
blocking plus two plus
two so
wait I'm confused can I not just
do yeah this blocks this because it's
going to be able to have this right and
then we just use a token on this two
blockers uh and then we use this here so
then this actually kills this
right Hearthstone has words like battle
Yeah they have they have
um yeah keywords
Enchanted
creature gets plus three plus three okay
so now I win right and now I uh all
attack which is
fine does this do anything if I
five3 yes this does this is worth it
because this kills this
[Music]
okay uh five
67 do I wait no blocks I'm
confused I can do this yeah okay it's
just the UI so I can do this and this
dies
um sure
and then all
attack and I win
cool and that's the tutorial
and they give you oh cool they actually
do give you some
decks they give you a goblin deck as
well
cool uh yeah the colors have archetypes
I know that yeah red is H Red's the
aggro deck
is it
352 let me make
sure okay well I have a little time so
I'll go play like a game or whatever
versus uh versus a
okay
would love to contribute pull up
we're going to do uh I said I'll host a
chat in it's discord.gg SLP puffer later
today I'll host a thing just watch in
there I'll just host something in voice
um and we can chat like this all the
stuff I do is open source right so like
yeah we we want people to help stuff cuz
I don't have time to do this whole thing
like alone even if I wanted to um my
thinking is probably I will at least get
the Prototype code uh written myself on
stream or whatever and then I will need
people to actually pick it up from there
choose
deck why can't I I can't play like mono
red
these oh yeah yeah I forgot there's a
mull again okay
cool uh
just join dis we'll look out yeah
basically I've got uh after this I'm
going to Ping uh my colleague to have an
initial meet and then after that I'll
probably uh start something on the
Discord
basically uh what are we
Mulligan Mulligan is whole new hand
actually isn't it
I mean I have a land I have two lands in
a one drop right no I have a two this is
a two
drop is that
okay dinosaur burning Sun I don't think
that this is
great
Mulligan pick your poison
dude what the heck is
this well I have to keep five cuz
like not going to have keep lands and
just hope we're
good drag two cards to the bottom of
your library
yeah I think I screwed up I should have
just not
Mulligan
Mountain what do we have we want this
yeah Target creature
gains well no I don't want to do that
thank
you pass
land
drag put them on the top of your library
wait
what put them on the top of your
library hey pubs we're thinking about
doing an
mtgm but uh I don't understand what the
[ __ ] let's
see I still can't play anything I think
I just screwed Myself by mulliganing by
uh I I just screwed myself cuz I had a
way better initial
hand yeah I literally can't do anything
I don't have any
creatures uh yeah I just have to keep
clicking resolve until I get smacked
here would be a lot of work to cold
every card property
yep I mean it'll be an incremental thing
right
okay I got to hurry this up
though uh oh I can play
this target
dinosaur deals
damage equal to its
power gain
May reveal a dinosaur in your
hand so can I do
this and then reveal
this
submit and then you gain
life I think I'm just screwed here
though because I don't
have
yeah choose blockers uh well I'll block
with this for
sure and wait plus one plus
three so I
can until R until end of
turn plus one plus
three oh yeah so I can actually take out
his best card here right if I wait what
why didn't I get to play this it's an
instant I don't know understand what
happened why did I not did I not have
Mana oh I didn't have Mana okay I'm
three five you need one green
Mana
yeah this Taps for
either so can I just do this and then
confused am I
stuck oh deals damage equal to its power
to another creature okay cool
and do I have this is already
tapped I should not have done all of
that stuff so
yeah creature has an abbility deals
damage yeah I read it
one
two take this
lovely discover
five discard
trumpeting it deals three damage to
Target
creature Target creature gains Menace
can't be blocked
wait what the
heck discover five what am I supposed to
do discover five I don't understand what
I'm supposed to do pay
for oh I have to choose what Mana to pay
I
see uh that's fine
I but how do I I can't pay more I don't
have that I'm
confused why did it let me do
right uh so he has to block with two
here but he can choose the order of
blocks so
first it's a creature for six Mana
second you can discard it yeah why did
it even let me do that because I don't
have six
Mana I guess there's uh some missing
action masking
deals I don't understand why it lets me
um it lets me like attempt to play this
if I don't have manage for it
oh wait can you tap creatures is that a
thing
no I don't
understand drag to order the creatures
blocking okay so I get to choose the
order of the creatures
blocking
cool UI is a bit wonky
yeah so we
destroy why oh I have a view Battlefield
so this is 8
N I have an 8 n so I these have to add
to
nine so I
destroy wait four five six seven8 n so
he has actually nine worth of
stats I don't think it matters I think
they all annihilate regardless don't
they no was I
wrong I don't
reach yeah this is Jank cuz I can't even
tap it right like there's literally I
don't
have I literally don't have the Mana I
don't know what's up with the UI
uh I literally can just do
lose yeah I just
lose okay
cool let me double check if uh Aaron is
around
I'll start uh another game we'll see
when he's free he said a round
four uh I kind of hate this deck I'm not
going to lie though I probably don't
understand what the heck is happening
with it
you deal damage in order and have to
assign lethal damage so if you'd swapped
have killed an extra creature yeah I
thought that I thought that that was
what it was but then I thought like I
then I thought N I thought I had the ma
the math wrong okay so a bunch of
lands uh and literally no
creatures uh
whatever at least now we have Lance
I assume that there are deck limits on
stuff right otherwise you would just
always put like these multi lands
in creature I I don't have Mana for
this put the
a what do we
want probably want this
right my uh my message is not sending
hold
on four of a certain card
Max many basic lands
okay this land
and then I I literally have one creature
so we do
this then do I have a
spell
sacrifice
enchantment sacrifice is a creature with
flying they have anything with flying
no target creature
so create two one one red goblins
okay this is the freaking deck I want
does he have like he has the mono red
aggro deck right
uh I still do not have anything I can
play here right
hand choose
attackers
I think you attack here so that he can't
clear
it wait
what why did he block with everything
I'm confused
yeah
oh
Doo
okay so
mountain and then I can play this maybe
if you do MTG I'm sure I will be able to
do
Uno yeah I would hope so is that Spencer
oh no that's spinter okay
die because I need this to I need this
to summon next turn
right reveal a
dinosaur or if you control another
dinosaur gain two
put on the battlefield then
Shuffle I think I do this because this
just gives me life
right
yeah and then this will be all
attack well wait
no uh this is a
dinosaur so can I do this
charitable answer is if you had a combat
trick that increased stats he can ensure
the death of your creature at the
expense of more of his own run reason
the multi
block I
see complicated things
cool oh you can pay two to deal damage
equal to its power to another
creature so yeah I can just wipe
his uh so auto
pay and then I Target this I do this and
that destroys
it each opponent this doesn't matter do
next do all attack
goodeve a dinosaur or if you control
another D yeah this is fine right
yeah Basic
[Music]
cool uh
next attack
attackers and I think I win
right first human RL MTG then computer R
yeah pretty much
to each opponent so does this actually
kill him is
he this is oh when you tap
it
okay yeah I just win
right
yeah cool
promise and you have to just beat three
times total not three in a row
right I
get uh a card cool
card uh this is actually this is
annoying but this is good right because
I have a two Mana card
can't attack this turn so we go
next
turn
creature Co he can't attack
[Music]
uh pass can't attack
right and my
this and reach until end of this turn
this gives
me three damage I don't know if that's
worth
it I guess this is worth using
now um because otherwise I waste Mana
and we
[Music]
play what do we need we need
green so wait what's this
two I can't play this
yet title of stream I literally said at
sports book I used to work I was playing
valerent League of Legends to model the
games
that's
here two
three I mean I can block this
thing
damage can I play this here oh and then
I can play this scry
s drag cards to put them on top or
bottom of your
library okay
oh wait you can put them on the top or
the
bottom uh I think I want the
land
yeah so this
is why did he just do
that okay I think I just win
here um
I can play
this but this doesn't really help right
oh wait no it does
because you may pay
two
right auto
pay and then this is going to destroy
this
right and then I can go next and I can
attach and he can't
block oh wait I thought you can't block
with a uh a tapped or oh no it's not
tapped it's Summoning Sickness
okay uh do
this any number of creature cards from
your hand I don't have any
oh I can't I don't have enough okay
Target creature gains plus three plus
three yeah we'll do this
okay wonky UI wins yeah yeah well it's
just awkward as a new player cuz it's
like I assume it means that there's
something I'm missing but it's
not Target creature gains
indestructible okay why is he helping me
I'm confused
122 and I
win
cool
47 and that was quick i' still have time
for one more so I'll hopefully finish
this little
tutorial people have complained about
this that's whatever
that doesn't matter that
much uh Black Card
okay I would really just like the uh
like the mono red goblins deck or
whatever that the opponent
had that would be really easy and simple
to start
with initial Mulligan choice this is
good right got a lot of low cost
ones so this is I don't have red Mana uh
is the problem
right maybe this wasn't so
good I have to hope I draw a mountain
card or
whatever yeah okay this is a bad open
very bad
right okay so I can actually uh discover
five discover Exile cards until you
Exile a
nonland but the rest till you Exile
along
interesting so I can play either of
these I don't think I can actually play
this can
I yeah I can't actually play
this uh can I play this I should be able
to play this
choose blockers
what why I am confused why did he do
that perfect I get I get
this and
then can't be blocked this looks
cool what can I not pay
four oh cuz this is already tapped
right shoot yeah that's already
four uh Target creature I think that
this is just decline
right rumbling
whatever or you summon this and
now pass to attackers but he can't
attack my
turn so I summon this
deals one
damage and now I have nice
carpet what
carpet uh one two three four
five I get
this wait I have five Mana I can play
this right this is a glitch I can't play
this in the background
is yeah I think we just literally do
this uh and he'll block one of these but
we don't care because
damage
right okay so he blocks this takes
if you control a creature add two Mana
but I think he loses anyways right
because uh okay
interesting I think we do no
blocks health is
resource
and play a forest
and then any number of creatures from
your hand into the
battlefield oh can I still not play
this no I still cannot play this that's
okay put something into
hand
cool and that is the uh the what second
to tutorial
duel okay so it's PVP
thing oh you get to add it to okay
that's cool
okay that's kind of
cool uh I
think ready in about 20
minutes I might have time to do this
real
this good
evening currently I am uh attempting to
figure out how on Earth I'm going to
implement something like this as an
rln what's the research card game
environment for RL
yeah name of the game around here is
reinforcement learning so yes this is me
just playing Magic but also I have a
bunch of meetings today on this and I do
not understand this game well enough uh
to be qualified to talk about it
so I'm currently trying to understand it
better deal one damage to Target
opponent
whenever another Outlaw enters deals one
damage so we do this and we do
this
right choose attackers this will just
die if it attacks right no no it won't
die uh I mean I can do this but I don't
think it'll do anything
that I don't understand why he let me do
that
presumably this is like like complete
new player mode
faster okay so we do this what's this
guy
mercenaries are mercenaries in addition
to their other
type
Exile uh you know what I do not know
what this does but
what oh he has to resolve okay
cool this guy has to
pay one oh I can't do that okay cool
that's the
glitch choose
attackers uh this 2
[Music]
two he can just block
right oh or he can do that and now I'm
screwed
combat
trick he valued his creature oh okay I
see I don't know if that's actually the
case though because this is literally
like the starter deck new player mode
right uh okay there goes my
field choose
damage so we do this get
land now sacrifice another
creature Outlaw create a treasure
token I kind of want to just do
this and this can attack right because
he can't block yep
thing
yeah it's fine
Target is this an
outlaw no this is not an outlaw
right creature
no so
uh so basically right
now on that
you
a sacrifice three
Treasures crime targeting
opponents is a
crime can I play
this or I play this
use
attackers this is a three
four I
just I don't think he can do anything
here
so now can he do 10 damage in a turn I
don't think
so I think if he attacks I just win next
turn right unless he has other
stuff creatures you control gain death
touch and life
length okay
blockers
creature uh I can't do anything about
this he's going to gain two
life oh [ __ ] they all had LifeLink okay
I didn't see that
yeah that's annoying I would have won
right there there I F the LifeLink I
hadn't
seen he healed off of it he healed six I
believe he healed either six or
eight uh and now I'm just dead because
yeah that was
dumb okay I think he's going
to well he literally could just prevent
himself from winning there if he'd
rolled a uh a
uh okay well here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to go uh over to this hold
on I'm going to go over to this uh this
meeting
whoops I'm going to where's this stupid
thing let me find the restraint
okay I'm going to go over to this uh to
this meeting um and then after that I'm
probably going to jump on the puffer
Discord discord.gg puffer and I will be
happy to
discuss um yeah discuss details of
environment and what we're thinking of
implementing from
there anyways thanks folks and I will uh